ciao a tutti allora spero che l'estate
sia andata bene a tutti quanti io di mio
l'ho passata da solo con cane a casa
mentre i miei parenti si sono divertiti
per un mese e mezzo in sicilia ingiusto
assolutamente giusto se mi seguite su
twitter questo già lo sapete e saprete
pure che i miei parenti sono tornati e
con loro è tornato il caos più totale
è come se mi scusassi in faccia fico ma
parliamo di altro che è meglio perché
dopo la pausa estiva o 2000 cose da
raccontare e di mele allora dico mi
prometti però che non lo dice nessuno
atti male che vada in giro cose tasto
non lo so non mi farei i bull hare con
dello stato a crudo ma non sono di base
sono contento però poi mi passa nulla e
mi arrabbio vado su e vado giù volte
corda ma come ti perdi ti già una cosa
assurda
perché stai prendendo appunti ma è così
perché ti voglio tenerlo bene il suo
segreto dai continui non è comunque di
base il vero motivo c'è poco da
prendersi in giro e che sono fatti miei
comunque il motivo per cui faccio questo
video così poi di botto perché avevo un
bisogno assolutamente forte di di
mettere qualcosa su you tube di
umiliarmi ancora di più perché dopo un
mese di vacanza è che non lo so non ho
la più pallida idea però io ho
assolutamente bisogno di parlare di un
argomento ben preciso nascondendo come
al mio solito altri argomenti in maniera
un pochino più cerata perché mi diverto
a fare queste cose un po alla disney con
gli ark con quelle cose che piazze sotto
e le persone non le nota non è meta è
quello il motivo per cui lo stai facendo
non dalle bestie che si vogliono bene ma
quell altro bene come avrete capito sono
parecchio confuso in questo momento di
agitazione collettiva che poi sono
all'intercettazione mia che stress
plurale maiestatis continua kimi credo
di essere il motivo per cui faccio
questo video è perché voglio parlare di
segreti eh sì avrei pure potuto fare che
ne so una intro parlare che ne so fare
un video dove dove iniziò mi metto a
dire quali sono i tipi le tipologie di
persone e le tipologie di segreto come
fanno le persone a fare una gran cagata
sarebbe stata alla fine perchè perchè di
base di fronte a una cosa del genere si
può dare solamente una dritta non dite i
cazzi vostri a nessuno non dite i cazzi
vostri a nessuno perché se andate a dire
una cosa importante
quello da dire prima o poi ad un amico
che più caro di tecniche di pronto
intervento il mondo intero
e questo solitamente accade nell'ipotesi
migliore perché non sempre i vostri
fatti si fanno roma new york per caso le
cose solitamente vanno proprio così ciao
sono già nate amore ciao mi senti cosa
devo dirti ma devi promettermi che non
lo direi nessuna scherzi con temi tutto
che succede
ho dato il mio primo bacio d'alessandro
davvero
oh mi raccomando acqua in bocca è tesoro
stai tranquilla se in una botte di ferro
con me
ciao
pronto poi indovini un po giannetto
datata via d'alessandro pronto già ne ha
fatto tutto quello che si potesse fare
con la ne andro ea dell'acqua in bocca e
forse pure alcol pronto ascolta johnny è
insita d'alessandro è muta ed è ubriaca
[Musica]
[Applauso]
pronto janet è rimasta coinvolta in
un'orgia con alejandro forse è pablo è
rimasta incinta pure di un bambino con
13 dita dei piedi pronto pronto
ascoltate janet è stata rapita da un
branco di narcotrafficanti via roma nord
è una mia nuova stuprato nel conto la
voce come le si rimetta cosa ingiusta la
vita non ci crederai mai hanno preso
janet per fare il continuo di xena
principessa guerriera che giorno un
peccato che sia una [ __ ]
la perla di saggezza di oggi è se avete
qualcosa da dire non lo dite
tenetevi i fatti vostri per voi oppure
parlate con i vostri parenti che loro
non mi tradiranno mai anche se poi ci
stanno tutte quelle cose tipo hansel e
gretel i parenti sono cattivi quindi
parlate con i vostri amici immaginari
che ancora meglio non venivo dire
incenso mirra come se fosse un presepe
che mi dicesse non si è tenere un
segreto
no è che cacchio cosa ne pensate
[Musica]